just weeks to go and in key marginal
constituencies across the country
campaigning is in full swing if you're
in one of the seats that's up for grabs
you'll be bombarded by parties clamoring
for your votes peterborough feels much
like marginal seats used to held by the
Tories wanted by Labour minority parties
not too much of a factor so I thought
I'd see to what extent the main parties
key messages of breaking through first
the Tory slogan which party has a
long-term economic plan later Neil for
you try again to which party says that
they have a long-term economic plan you
have no idea you could try again you
could try one more time Yuki I think we
could have been at that all afternoon it
was certainly keeping some people
entertained so what about an emblematic
labor policy the energy price freeze
might that have taken flight here which
party says they would freeze your energy
bills conservative and then I'll said
that which party says they would freeze
your energy bills
I was a neighbor you're getting help
from and which party says that they
would freeze your energy bills
conservative over labor which party says
that they have a long-term economic plan
conservatives there were some exceptions
of course there were which party says
that they would freeze your energy bills
labor you are listening to what the
parties are saying but you're in a
minority why do you think so many people
are not tuned in at the moment I think
that the distrust with politicians
basically lots of my friends I've spoken
to said they don't know which way to
vote hmm and a lot of people who have
always continue what voted either for
the Tories or for labor and in this
election they're really really not sure
I think because generally most of us
don't believe what's big being said by
the major parties anyway I don't pay a
great deal of attention because most of
it's just rubbish so it seems to a large
extent people are not listening it makes
you wonder will they tune in and take an
interest at some point or will this
election be largely characterized by
voters inclined to turn their backs on
this place soon we'll know the answer